hi everyone i'm danny ceo and welcome to
a brand new
culinary edition of do just one thing
and today i call it why buy it when you
can diy it and what i'm talking about
are your own diy apple cider vinegar
gummies
yes you can actually make them yourself
and if you know
anything about apple cider vinegar right
now it is
all the rage and there's so many things
that people love about apple cider
vinegar the one thing that can be a
little difficult about it is that it's
not easy
to take your apple cider vinegar on the
go you imagine traveling with this
so one of my favorite things to do is to
make these really delicious
apple cider vinegar gummies because you
can take one or two or a whole bunch of
them
and enjoy your apple cider vinegar
gummies wherever
you go what you start off with
is some gelatin so what i have here is
unflavored gelatin just three packets
which equals about three tablespoons
you can find uh vegan alternatives to
gelatin too at the health food store but
you need something that's going to be
that binding agent
that makes everything into that jelly
form
that we want in our gummy bear so i just
sprinkle three of these in here and what
we want to do in this bowl
is called blooming we want the gelatin
to bloom
into a thick paste don't be scared by
the paste
it's kind of ugly but it's all going to
come together in the end and be a really
beautiful mixture that you're going to
want to chill
make beautiful gummies out of the very
next thing is you need a little bit of
lemon juice
and what i love to do is just
quarter them up just like this you can
also just squeeze them regularly but you
need about
two tablespoons of lemon juice
and what i've discovered that equals
about half a lemon
depending how juicy your lemons are
here's the last one
one of the nice things about this recipe
is that it's very forgiving so
if you have a little too much lemon
juice in there it's totally okay it's
all going to come together
and then finally because apple cider
vinegar if you've ever taken a shot
of apple cider vinegar you know it's
very pungent a little bit of sweetness
you know as you say a little bit of
sugar helps the medicine go down
well so does honey and what we're going
to do is put
three tablespoons of honey in here you
can do
an organic honey you can do a raw honey
but what i like to do is just
take whatever i have on hand
and pour this beautiful golden mixture
you only need about
five minutes of time to really put it
all together and it makes a whole bunch
of gummies which is really nice oh and
one more thing
you need water so one quarter cup of
water
to really help bring it all together now
i talked about how
blooming the gelatin will result in
something that's not so
attractive and i'll show you what you
get
it's sort of this thick gunky paste
it kind of looks like like a sugar scrub
you might use in the shower
but this is exactly what you want and
you might be thinking
we're missing something yes we're
missing apple cider vinegar so
what i've got here is half a cup of
apple cider vinegar and half a cup of
water
just bring it to a boil turn it off
we're just going to pour this all the
way on the inside
and then we're going to incorporate it
all together and you want to make sure
that the gelatin
is totally dissolved there's no clumps
in here
and as you can see in a matter of
seconds i've got my mixture
ready to go to be made
into apple cider vinegar gummies
and by the way i went online you don't
have to do this
and i bought these silicone molds in the
shape of apples
but whatever silicone mold you have is
totally fine
if you don't have a silicone mold what
you can do
is actually repurpose like an empty
juice container something with the waxy
inside
and just fill that whole thing with this
mixture
and then open it up and then cut it into
little squares and little square gummies
from that
now we're just going to fill our mulch
with the mixture one by one and just so
you guys know i have it on a plate
i learned the very hard way that if you
pour
anything into a silicone mold and it's
not on a steady surface when you try to
pick it up
you make a big hot mess in the kitchen
very quickly
and then into the refrigerator for about
30 minutes or overnight
i did one ahead of time this is what it
looks like
so you can see take this one out that it
is completely
solidified and they just pop right out
and you have a homemade apple
cider vinegar gummy and what do we say
why buy it
when you can
diy it if you're planning on making some
of these apple cider vinegar gummies
post it to your social media accounts
and be sure to tag the drew barrymore
show in your post
and don't forget we have so many recipes
and ideas and inspiration
at the drewberrymarshow.com website and
if you're even more inspired you can
find a lot more recipes in my own
magazine naturally danny seo
now on newsstands
[Music]
you